I'm glad to be here um I'm going to talk
today about mainly about active nearest
neighbors in metric spaces I'm also
going to talk about another thing in the
end so this talk is about doing actual
learning and I'm sort of kind of goal
for me to try to do active learning
under minimal assumptions so we don't
want to sort of assume something then go
try run it then it doesn't work because
our assumptions were wrong but it's too
late because we already sort of spent
our budget for instance so this is sort
of the focus I'm going to talk mostly
about active nearest neighbor in metric
spaces with this is joint work with the
Contra origin with owner and in the end
I will talk a little bit about active
linear regression this is work with
every Munoz ok so just to remind us all
what we mean when he says active
learning is a specific type of
interactive learning a very maybe
structured type so first let's remind
ourselves passive learning in passive
learning I'm talking about supervised
passive learning I have some sample of
examples I have for each example the
corresponding label this is my training
set I feed it to my computers say the
computer learns the model the model is
kept somewhere and then when there's a
new example say these three here then
using the model I will the model will be
used to sort of output the right label
okay so this is standard passive
learning and the problem that we're
dealing with in active learning is we
don't want to actually require all of
these labels here this is in many cases
this can be very expensive in many cases
examples are actually easy to count on
so it is it to find a lot of images etc
but labels could be much more expensive
so we want to save that so this is the
problem that we're dealing with here
so in active learning the idea is ok
instead of just asking for all of the
labels in advance let's just have some
mechanism some Oracle that will be able
to give us labels it could be a person
in case of digits it could be maybe an
experiment if we're in a biology setting
and we need to do experiments to get
labels so this person in this example so
the model gets a set of samples but
without the labels and then it can sort
choose some example from here you ask
the person or the Oracle what is the
label of this example get the example
back etc and then in the end we do the
classification the same as before based
on the model that we got from this
learning process so the goal is mainly
okay we want to select smartly which
examples to label so that we can save
dollars or whatever other resources that
we pay for getting labels that's the
main goal in activate so one topic we in
which I think it's safe to say that we
know quite a lot today about active
learning is in the case of parametric
learning so in parametric learning we
assume that there is some fixed limited
capacity concept class that we said in
advance say it could be linear
predictors in some space or it could be
decision trees or it could be anything
else and we try to approach the best the
error of the best concept in this class
so this is parametric learning and I
will talk about classification so I'm
assuming there is some small discrete
set of possible levels say the numbers
or sometimes even just binary
classifications to labels so for this
type of model where we have active
parametric clubbing for classification I
think we know quite a lot about it there
has been a lot of work during recent
years much of it by people in this room
and we know a lot about realizable
setting but the agnostic setting we have
disagreement based algorithms we have
margin based algorithms we have near
optimal strategies in some cases we have
lower bound we know a lot and this is
very interesting in good progress but
then it doesn't solve all our problems
because this is just for the parametric
case and just for classification so
today I'm going to talk about two
problems that do not fall into this
setting mostly I will talk about the non
parametric setting and then I will talk
about regression which is also not a
classification problem because the
labels are not discrete so ok let's talk
about nonparametric learning what do we
mean by non parametric learning I just
mean that we don't assume any specific
concept class in general in
particularly you usually expect that if
your training set is larger your the
complexity of your complex concept class
is concept is larger or your model and
in this model we just try to approach
the base we don't sort of compare us off
to specific concepts we just try to
approach the best possible error for a
classification specifically I'm going to
talk about approaches that use nearest
neighbor classification so I'm assuming
symmetric space and then in this space
I'm looking at a method that does the
following so first it looks at the
sample using the sample it creates some
database so the database will be just a
set of labeled examples and then based
on this database it will classify new
examples using the nearest neighbor rule
so any new example that comes in I will
find which is the example closest to it
in my database and I will give it the
same label okay so very sort of
intuitive way of doing things so I will
look at this sort of setting and what
I'm going to do in this work is the
following I'm going to present a nearest
neighbor active learner that has a
competitive accuracy to a passive
learner which I will describe that is
designed to have this sort of property
to use a nearest neighbor rule and the
goal of the active learner is to try to
use less labels now it's not always
possible to use less labels but if it's
possible we would like to be able to do
that and we don't want to make any
assumptions on the distribution so the
algorithm should just run it doesn't
need you don't need to tell it anything
before it starts running and we want of
course finite sample guarantees I would
like to have in this field a central
challenge which I will get to after a
few other discussions is active model
selection so what happens here
unlike the fixed concept class case is
that we have to somehow decide on the
complexity of our model and it's it's a
challenge in active learning because
usually to do that what you do is you
just try a lot of different models in
passive learning that's not too bad but
in active learning every time you try
different model you might pay a lot of
labels and you don't want to do that for
all the different models just is to
choose one model India
it's a serious challenge there is some
related work on nonparametric active
learning but again I think in general
it's much maybe sparse or less sort of
we have less of a general picture of
what is going on in that space some some
works are listed on this slide we have
cluster based active learning we have
minimax right under decision boundary
regularity we have some graph based
active learning in in this setting in
general these these are very interesting
works what I'm trying to do which is
different is to sort of try to get rid
of all the assumptions sort of not try
to assume anything in advance and also
it's a good time to mention that this
afternoon we have Steve there talking
about he's a nearest neighbor active
learning work which is also very
interesting okay so let's be a bit more
formal we're assuming symmetric space x
width symmetric row there's a finite set
of labels in this case so in the multi
class setting and we assume some unknown
distribution over the examples in the
label joint distribution and we have
some examples and labels drawn from the
distribution this is our input this is
our training set basically and the
output we want the output to be just a
classifier that gets examples and
outputs labels the goal here is to just
find get a low error so we want the
probability of making a mistake on a new
random pair to be small using our
learned classifier so this is just a new
public learning in general for our model
why do when I'm going to compare passive
learning to active learning so let's
just define that so passive learning I
get a sample as it's a random iid sample
out of my distribution of size M and
I'll put a classifier in the active
learning case I'm going to talk about
pool based active learning so I'm
getting a pool the pool is just the
examples without the labels and I can
just interactively request some of the
labels I can
for give me the label of example3 I will
get the label then I can ask for another
label etc and I can do this
interactively and again I will output a
classifier okay so the only difference
is the way that I'm getting the labels I
don't pay for them all in advance I can
choose which of them I want to pay for
so this is active learning passive
learning now let's talk a little bit
about the nearest neighbor rules I'm
going to talk about one year sniper so
it's a very simple approach you fix some
label said I'm going to say what it is
in a moment so some some set of examples
with labels and this is basically our
model and then every new examples that
we get will just find the example that's
closest to it
in this set l and label it the same so
if I'm drawing this basically each color
here is allowable basically every every
point induces the region around it which
will have the same color and if I get a
new point I will just check which which
is in which one I sell it lies and this
is what determines my label so this is a
one nearest neighbor rule in the passive
learning case there are some approaches
that were talking about so in general
what is the general form if we're in a
passive setting we want to build the one
nearest neighbor model what we basically
need to do is we just take the training
sample which we know we need to use it
to set some else some set of labeled
examples and then this this set will be
used as our nearest neighbor database
now the classical I'll know about is one
nearest neighbor which just says okay
take just the whole training set this is
your database okay this is a very simple
very intuitive approach so in this case
L equals just a sip what I'm going to
talk about today is a more sophisticated
algorithm that has some advantages it's
a compression based algorithm passive
learning algorithm in this algorithm the
L the training the database that I'm
going to use is a subset of the training
set so I'm not going to choose all of
the training set not necessarily I might
choose a subset this is a work by
gottlieb control which Krauthammer and
they're wise and what they do is they
propose this algorithm the advantages of
this algorithm okay so first of all by
taking a subset of course first of all
it it could be better right I mean we
could just be able to compress our data
set we don't have to save all the data
set in our model that's of course useful
computationally also what we get is this
is something this is a way to regularize
basically our choice of data sets so
instead of just choosing the entire set
we can choose a smaller set and by this
way we can get the generalization error
to be actually smaller because we don't
have this basically fixed uncontrolled
set that we are using on the
distribution now what I mean is I will
select the set hell I will talk about it
a little bit more in a moment but I will
select the set L such that my sort of
bound for the arrow in the distribution
is small okay that's what I'm trying to
do right and for this type of algorithm
we have a finite sample and data
dependent error guarantees so based on
the data set that we saw in the L that
we chose we can have guarantees and the
regularization that comes from being
able to choose the data set gives us
more control over the final error so
we're going to look at this passive
learning algorithm and so this is sort
of our benchmark we want to try to do
something similar to that but we want to
try to do it using active learning and
less labels so I'll first introduce our
main result and then I will go back to
how we do that so we proposed this new
algorithm Moorman which is a one years
neighbor active learner and the
guarantee is with respect to the
guarantee of this passive learner so the
passive learner basically guarantees
that the error that it gets is smaller
than some generalization bound which is
depend which depends on the sum
input sample this is empirical bound
which is based on compression bounds
what we what we guarantee instead is
that we have an active learner and it
obtains an error bound which is up to a
constant the same as the error bound of
the passive learner so we pay by some
constant factor of the only error so
this is the competitiveness with the
accuracy but then the advantage is that
we will require less labels so basically
the number of labels that we require is
about log 1 over Delta 1 over g plus mg
where g is basically our guarantee for
the error of the output classifier ok so
what happens here is if j is very large
or very small then we don't gain much
we're just basically going to use the
whole pool of examples and ask for all
the labels but we do gain if g is
somewhere in the middle okay so the best
case would be when g is about 1 over
square root of M so this is the error
that we guarantee and in this case we
will use about square root m labels
instead of M which is the size of the
entire pool so this is type of a
luckiness result I mean if we are in a
in a setting where it's where G is very
large or very small we're not going to
get improvement but if we can't we will
okay this is
so it depends on what you can do I will
maybe we'll define it in a moment and
you will be easier to see that so yes so
just to be clear when you do the subset
based on a compression bound you have to
do that after you've looked at the
labels of everything so you can't just
naively say that yeah so I will I will
kind of get into more detail in a moment
and we will see what the passive learner
does so G is kind of whatever the active
learner gets is manages to do making
noise alright so the thing is of course
to get an improvement in the number of
labels I need G to be good but I
guarantee accuracy no matter what so the
point is I think it will it will be
easier to see once I sort of show some
of the algorithm okay and it will be
clear when the where these two terms
come from okay so let's talk about what
is the algorithm and I will start with
explaining the passive algorithm for a
moment and then which will be easier to
also explain the active algorithm so I
will first talk about the passive
algorithm and then I will explain the
different parts of the active element so
so the passive learner algorithm works
as follows first it looks at the data
and it it wants to find basically a
separated sense so what's a separated
set let's say we have a scale gamma and
gamma separated set is a set where a
sample is a set where two examples if
they are gamma neared and they don't
have different labels okay so every
label every two examples that are not
the same level our gamma far that's a
gamma separated sample of course the
original sample should not be a gamma
separated sample but then what the
passive algorithm does it does the
following first it removes all the
points that interfere with this gamma
separation so basically you can think
is some sort of noise reduction removing
noise from the sample and then it will
define a gamma naught gamma half net on
the rest of the points and this half
gamma net is a compression set that can
be used as a nearest neighbor database
okay so I'm sorry you can think of it as
a mark if you remove after you remove
the noise
you might workspace I'm not sure about
John something a stress knows how to do
for John or metric space so metric space
so this is basically what you can do
when you if you decide on his scale your
scale is gamma then you can say okay
here is my gamma compression I will
remove the things that make noise in
this gamma scale and then I will just
just select this half gamma net on the
rest of the data okay but this is just
after you know yeah okay so I sort of
told you I have some scale gamma and use
that scale in reality we don't know game
is again it's not a parameter of the
algorithm what happens is we are going
to find gamma okay yes when you're
trying to remove these gamma separated
points you have some choices does it
matter yes there are choices what you
want to do is you want to remove the
smallest number of such points in the
this is actually a special case of a
vertex cover problem so it's easy to do
if there are two blades if there are
more than two levers you can do a two
approximation I want to remove the
minimum number of points and I will show
that in a minute because it will be come
up in our bands yeah I want to say with
the largest best set possible I want
basically think of it intuitively if I
have to remove a small number of points
this is like saying there was little
noise in my data which is of course a
good thing little noise is
think so a small number of points little
noise so here exactly this is a real
question so let's let's do you know by
nu of gamma the smallest fraction of
point that needs to be removed to get a
gamma separation this is again related
to the vertex cover problem on a graph
we find on this sample and what we have
is a compression based upper bound for
gamma so given a fixed gamma scale the
generalization error is going to depend
on new of gamma the fraction of points
that I had to remove plus these terms
that depend on n gamma which is the size
of the gamma net and the size of the
sample and log 1 over Delta which is our
confidence okay so this is a compression
bound it's not very easy to to show it's
shown again in this previous work on a
passive learner and the idea is that
okay we have this bound we have this
bound for every scale gamma let's just
choose the best skin we will try all the
different scales on will choose the best
one the one that minimizes this
generalization so this is what the
passive algorithm does now we want to
compete with that passive Allwood okay
so our goal is to get similar error
guarantees but we want to do it actively
and we want to save labels we don't want
to use very many labels so what we need
to do is we first need to select gamma
using few labels this is our model
selection problem and second we need to
give in gamma set the data base L also
using few labels okay now this is not
not trivial because the algorithm that I
just showed you does not take this
integral it doesn't care it can look at
all the labels it wasn't designed to use
few lights so even though the algorithm
first selects gamma and then sets the L
given gamma I'm going to explain it the
other way around because the second one
is easier okay let's just assume we have
gamma and we just want to settle so if
we have gamma we want so if we wanted to
do what the algorithm I just told you
does we would have to sort of find the
minimal number of points to remove from
the sample to make it gamma separable
but this is a hard problem in terms of
doing this with a small number of
of labels it's also computationally hard
if you have more than two labels and you
can only get it to approximation so
instead we do something else what we do
is the following we start with setting a
gamma net so we define a gamma net L
till the gamma which is 1/2 gamma net on
on the original sample without removing
any noise after we did that we take each
point in the gamma net and we randomly
sample randomly sample labels from the
Voronoi cell around it and check what is
the majority label and what we do then
is we set the label of each of these
points in the gamma net to the label of
the majority around it or the estimated
majority around it so what this means is
unlike the original algorithm we don't
just take a sub sum a subset of the
labeled examples we take a subset of the
examples but we put our own labels on
them ok so it's a bit different it's not
the standard the totally standard
compression scheme but it's not also
very far from it so you know the sort of
a compression with side information
because you want to be able to change
the label and then you can show
basically even we start information it's
almost the same so generalization error
that we get is almost the same yes
now here are my seemingly no gap not
exactly I will show you I will show this
we actually we don't actually do what
you're saying so it's actually not what
we're going to do I will talk about it
going to talk about actor model
selection and the reason is because this
is the way that we need to do to save
labels okay so but let's just for a
moment stay with a fixed gamma so for a
fixed gamma we have a generalization
bandage can be given and we can show
that the this gamma net that I've just
defined gets the error which is a
constant times the new gap knew of gamma
the same new that we had before in the
passive algorithm so this is a very good
approximation and basically what happens
here is once you know gamma the number
of labels that you need is going to be
proportional to the size of the gamma
net now this may look like a lot and it
could be a lot but it's also the only
thing that you can do because basically
there are a lot of bands you can show
that in general you do need this number
of labels to be able to get an error
which is competitive with the error of
the original scale the algorithm you
just randomly sample label so it's run
its randomly sampled labels in each
Voronoi cell over gamma net it it's
almost randomly yeah okay so so the
point here is okay so we need an N of
gamma points in order to end gamma
labels in order to get this right and
this is a lower bound so where where is
our again our game is if gamma is large
if we happen to find that a large gamma
is good enough for our problem then n
gamma is going to be small and if n
gamma is going to be small then we're
happy because we used few labels okay
this is one way where you're asking what
type of problem will allow me to use
less light oh so this is one thing that
should should be happening is I need to
be able to use a large gamma okay
so in this in this algorithm it is
assumed to be uniform yes although of
course it probably can be improved to
not be uniform so this is a luckiness
idea and that is the entire I think idea
of the approach is I don't assume that
that the problem is easy but if it's
easy I'm going to get to be able to use
less labels gianna can be cunning oh
well it depends on the doubling
dimension essentially but for a fixed
problem of course if you increase gamma
your n gamma is more right I mean
they're almost touching each other of
the examples but you can take points
very far from them okay I'm not sure I
follow your example exactly but in
general the idea is just n gamma is the
size of the gamma net that's needed to
cover the space so the space of samples
obviously if you use a smaller gamma
then you need more exam or points in
your curve cover I mean
but it's not a hyperplane okay so if you
only have two points your gamma is very
large because the distance between them
okay what you're saying is it could be
that there is a poor separation but
there exists a small set which separates
that is true but you will not find this
set if you just use it like a worst case
gamma net okay you cannot get I cannot
guarantee that you will actually find
this that it could exist but he will not
necessarily find it because you're just
taking any gum in it not the best gamma
net so okay so the point is here if we
can find a good gamma which is larger
than where we're happy we have few
labels now how do we select a scale of
gamma so here's what we do so again our
challenge is active model selection we
need to find gamma but we want to use
few labels so we don't want to just try
all of the different gammas and do the
entire thing for all of them and we
basically what we want is the number of
levels at which is using that we use you
during this model selection algorithm
should only depend on the selected gamma
why because the selected glamour is
basically what I'm going to guarantee in
the end so it's okay to depend on that I
mean if I'm getting you a good gamma
that's okay that I'm using a lot of
labels for that good gamma but I don't
want to use a lot of labels for
something that I'm not even going to use
later okay so that's sort of our
challenge there is some previous work
interesting a previous work on active
model selection in the parametric
setting whether Nina Bell Kona Steve
Hanukkah and Jennifer workman but it's
not suitable for what we need so we're
proposing another approach and our
approach is basically some type of a
binary search I'm going to call it
binary search star because it's sort of
not exactly binary search but it it's
sort of a little bit into it intuitively
it's similar so how do we do that so
here's the idea so we have this bound
that we are trying to minimize over
gamma so
the mound is composed of two parts three
parts but it is based on two properties
one is nu gamma and the other is the
size of the Geminids now we can rewrite
this bound a little bit so that we can
see that it's basically composed of two
Kotov two of two sizes two quantities
one is again knew of gamma which is
sample dependent and the other is
something that I call Phi of gamma which
we can basically calculate just if we
know the size of the gamma net and the
size of the sample we don't need any
labels for it okay so fear of gamma is
something that we know knew of gamma is
something that we don't know in advance
so the the nice thing that happens is
the following if you as you increase
gamma nu of gamma is monotonic
increasing or non decreasing at least
and as you increase Gamma Phi of gamma
which is our penalty for the size of the
gamma net decreases okay so we have two
different quantities one is increasing
one is decreasing and we're looking to
minimize the sum of them okay so what we
do instead is we're looking using sort
of a binary search as I said binary
search star to look for a gamma where
they are both about equal it's not
necessarily it doesn't necessarily exist
so there are some details that you need
to take care of but let's just say for
this for the explanation that they do
exist and you should just find the place
where they are both the same if they're
about the same then you have a small
factor approximation to the minimal
bound that you're trying to get so based
on binary search you can basically say
if this one is much larger than this one
I should go right if this one is much
larger I should go left okay this is the
idea but it's not it's still not solving
the problem because we don't know new
gamma nu of gamma as I said it's
something that's hard to estimate it's
hard to find in the sample so what we do
instead is we look at the sample error
so the sample error is actually a lower
bound to Nu of young and the sample
error of a specific gamma net that we
chose and we can show that and this
means that now we have this epsilon of
gamma which the sample error for a
specific gamma scale it's not monotonic
it's not necessarily monotonic but it is
bounded by a monotonic north camera
using these these observations we can
sort of fix binary search stars so that
it still finds a good scale even though
it uses something which is not monotonic
based on this upper bound okay so I'm
not going to go into all the details you
have to be very very careful but if you
do it carefully then you can find a good
gamma scale now how many different
gammas have you looked at just
logarithmic in the number of the total
number of skills so okay there is still
one thing missing which is how do you
estimate this error the sample average
gamma and this is also non-trivial
because again I'm not actually going to
build the entire gamma net for each for
each scale I'm I want I don't want to do
that I will just cost me too much labels
too many labels so what we are doing
instead is and I think I will really
just mention this and not go into all
the details what we're doing instead is
we're estimating this sample error only
up to some accuracy and it turns out
that estimating the sample error up to a
specific accuracy suffice is for us to
decide whether we should go right or
left in the binary search and this
accuracy we set it so that we never pay
more than what we're actually going to
get in the end okay so if G as I said is
our final guarantee for the error then
the number of labels that I'm going to
use to estimate this sample error is
going to be the minimum between the 1 1
over the error in this gamma and 1 over
my penalty term for this gamma which
means that I'm not going to pay more
than 1 over G okay so again what this
means is I'm doing model selection I
don't know which is the right scale but
I can make sure that I never waste more
labels then what I am willing to waste
for the true skill which I don't know
okay so this is a bit of a delicate
thing that needs to be done but it can
be done and in this way we guarantee
that even though we look at a lot of
different scales and even though the
right scale might not be the one that
we're looking at right now we are never
going to spend too many labels on
checking this specific scale so I think
I'm going to skip the explanation how
exactly we do that I will just say in
general this is that this can be done
using a general solution to a problem of
estimating the expectation of a
Bernoulli variable using sort of
automatic stopping mechanism so we need
to basically know when to stop when we
estimate the the expectation of a
Bernoulli variable we can draw random
samples of this but not a variable and
we don't want to have to draw too many
so we have to know when to stop when we
have the desired accuracy no more and
this can be done using empirical
Bernstein bounds so I think I will not
go into all of these details now but
this is what we do to be able to do the
model selection yes and then you spend
all your time no so to find the right
gamma I need to estimate the sample
error at every point that I'm checking
right so when I find the right gamma
this is only then I will actually spend
these n gamma samples to actually get
the entire model so to do the estimate
I'm not actually calculating the time
between them so probably we can reuse
them but we haven't done the analysis in
this way different sizes ever are very
different
yes so the way that we defined it right
now you just have an arbitrary gamma net
over for every size but probably you can
build something that hierarchical so
that you don't have to re to resample
and it will probably save some labels
yes I'm not sure it will change the
order of everything but it probably will
save on the constants okay so to show
the entire algorithm like in schedule D
algorithm is the following so first we
do the binary search star which allows
us to select a value for gamma to do
that we estimate the error gamma of this
gamma so sample area of this gamma up to
some accuracy threshold which allows us
to not spend too many levels using this
procedure we can find a gamma star which
is a correct scale in the sense that it
is a scale that will give us up to a
constant away from the best accuracy
that one can achieve and this entire
process of the model selection costs us
about one over G labels so shy respect
to your question when G is small this
means that the error of the good model
is small and this means that we need
more samples to differentiate it from
another model which is almost as good so
we are paying one over G for the model
selection part so here we pay more if
the error is smaller now the second part
is okay I found a good gamma using this
model selection process now all I have
to do is just get this specific gamma
calculate the gamma that I defined
before calculate the majority vote vote
for every point in the gamma net which
will cost me all of n of gamma star
labels and this is basically the model
that I will output this is the data base
the nearest neighbor database that I
will out so here repeating again the
main result we see that the number of
labels that we need is really just the
sum of these two
g-star is the best error that you could
get if you actually checked all of the
skills to the to them to the entire
accuracy that you can get with the
entire sample so basically this is what
JSTOR is basically what the passive
learner would get there is more than one
governing that's true so for this
algorithm what we assume is you have
some procedure for finding a gamma net
for a given gamma I don't know what it
is I'm just assuming it exists and all
of my bounds rely on whatever procedure
you have so it's true that given one
gamma star there are more than one gamma
net possible but the differences in size
between them can be bounded to find the
minimum one is is np-hard but to find a
gamma net is easy and you can actually
bound the size the difference in sizes
between them the ratio even a very high
intuitive level the algorithm is
sampling in the dense regions less often
your probability of being sampled if
you're in a dense region is smaller
because this is um so okay so the word
no cells are not of equal size they are
based on the points that you sampled
so in that sense actually I don't think
this is true because if you do a gamma
net on the entire space you will have
Voronoi cells in dense spaces and in
sparse spaces and you will sample the
same amount we will sample the same
amount because at least the way that
this is a friend you need to get the
same accuracy for each one so there's
some cells many more well here we don't
need any more but if you want to wait
seven I say yes those weights will be
less likely
conception being adaptive in every part
of the data because at the end that's a
nearest neighbor algorithm they decide
the size of the cells according to mo
Genuity based on some samples that
estimate which is common to those
approaches and seems that the main
difference is whether gamma is uniform
throughout or you allow it to vary in
different areas so I have different
different guarantees right we don't have
any assumption on the distribution okay
so it is a luckiness guarantee I'm not
saying of course not every distribution
will gain but the point is that you can
you can just use it and whatever you get
you get I mean that's a lucky nice sort
of approach but we can talk about this
more flying so we also have some lower
bounds to show that at least some of
this is inevitable yes okay okay so
maybe I'll I'll talk about this a little
bit and I will mention the regression
problem also
so just decide that our lower bounds
show that you cannot get the same result
with a random sampling of the labels you
have to do something active and that the
MG the number mg that we have in our
label complexity you can't get rid of it
basically you have to have it if you
want to have this kind of guarantee okay
we don't know about the one overdue from
the model selection this we don't know
maybe it can be improved so okay I'll
just summarize this part really quickly
so that I can also mention the
regression part so basically we have
this algorithm it's basically a
luckiness based algorithm you don't need
any assumptions but if you're lucky then
you're going to use less labels and you
could you would have if you just use the
passive learner and we have some lower
bounds that show that in some respects
this is the best label complexity in
other respects it's still an open
problem and this is basically this
nearest neighbor approach
I do want to spend a few minutes also
talking about the regression problem
which is different so in the regression
problem we're looking at linear
regression we have examples in Euclidean
space we have labels the real values
we're looking at linear predictors and
we are just looking to minimize the mean
squared error of the predictor we do not
assume that there is a predictor that
gets zero error or even that the model
is well specified we just look to
minimize the excess loss of our
predictor compared to the best predictor
that you can get in this distribution so
we want to do again active learning and
the minimum sumption x'
and the arson previous works on active
learning for regression but they all
have different assumptions that we are
trying to not have in this approach so
the starting point of this algorithm was
the following result of I Daniel and I
are for passive learnings so this is an
passive learning algorithm for
regression that gets bands that are
tighter than standard least squares
regression bounds because it basically
handles heterogeneous noise so this is
an algorithm where if you have more
noise in one direction than in the other
you will actually sort of it will factor
into your bounds so that you can get
tighter bounds in heterogeneous noise
cases okay so this is a passive learning
algorithm and the point for this talk is
I want to make it active so what do I
mean by making it active it means I want
to sort of improve the number of labels
using an active using this bound but
improving the number of labels so the
main idea is the following this bound
depends on the distribution is of course
not surprising but the idea is we can
sort of change the distribution okay so
we have a distribution it's given to us
but we have active active learning which
basically means that we are we can we
can use more unlabeled samples but we
don't want to waste labels so what we
can do is we can take the distribution
we can sample examples from it but we
will only ask for some of the labels and
using rejection sampling we can use this
to sort of simulate at
different distribution okay so this is
the idea now what I want to do is I want
to find a distribution that will make
this bound as small as possible this is
a general idea let's simulate or emulate
a distribution and then run this
algorithm but will it will be a
different distribution so we will get a
better burn so we define a weight
function over our support which
basically specifies how to relay the
examples in the space and it can be
emulated using rejection sampling from
the distribution so it doesn't waste any
more labels and we build this
distribution so that the loss of the
decision on this distribution is the
same as the loss on the original
distribution so I can just do regression
on this new distribution whatever I get
is as good for the original distribution
there's no B and the main challenge is
how do you find such a good way a good
weight function right if I so this is
again sort of a model selection problem
although it's in a different context so
the thing is and I'm not showing you all
the details here but this Phi this
weight function actually depends on the
true predictor on the on the optimal
predictor the optimal of fire depends on
the optimal predictor so of course this
is a sort of a bootstrapping problem but
we can get around it by basically we'll
of course we have to limit fice somewhat
because we need some sort of a limited
capacity class for Phi but then what we
do is find an approximation for the
predictor so we find an approximation
for the predictor that we're looking for
just so that we can then find a good Phi
and then we calculate the optimal
predictor again based on this file so
I'll just show sort of the sketch of the
algorithm we have a budget labeled
budget we split it into three parts
where is the third first part to run a
regression on the labeled examples from
some normalized distribution and we get
some predictor V hat so this V hat is
not so good it cannot be used as our
output but it can be used to estimate
file so the second stage we're doing
another type of sampling from m2 labels
and get Phi hat which is our estimate of
the weight function
and then finally we run regression using
this new Phi hat on the last part of our
label budget so the idea is basically
you first do some learning you use it to
improve your weight function and then
you do the actual learning that will get
you the predictor that you're looking
for so this is kind of the sketch of the
algorithm and the type of guarantee that
we get here is actually similar in the
idea to what we got before so we get the
following guarantee we get that the
excess loss that our algorithm gets is
almost the same as if as if we knew the
correct fight to use from the beginning
it's almost the same because there is
some overhead that comes from having to
estimate file but this overhead is
asymptotically smaller so we are left
with this right which is again
comparative with what you could get if I
told you in advance the right fight to
use so this is ver star this is the
optimal convergence rate and we are
basically approaching it using this
algorithm any questions
how do you speak to people in Baltic
between M 1 M 2 M 3 in work there so the
way that it split is M 3 is the largest
it basically in when M goes to infinity
M 3 will be almost the entire budget and
the other ones are going to so I don't
have it here on the slides but you can
actually if you know the distribution
you can actually find an analytic
expression that tells you what is the
best file but of course we don't know
the distribution that's why we have to
estimate it
this port or just a progression or some
other linear models oh I haven't tried
so that's a good question
okay so let's just I'll just summarize
in both of these approaches what we're
showing is we have we do active learning
we don't have any assumptions on the
distribution we just sort of try to run
an algorithm and hope for the best in
the sense that whatever it can get it
will get and if not then okay we still
got about the same accuracy as the
passive learner so that's a general idea
and so we either get competitive
accuracy with less labels or we get
better accuracy with competitive number
of labels and we need to do that we need
to estimate the parameters of the
problem interactively which is what we
do and as I said before this is a
luckiness sort of result so the actual
improvement will depend on the
distribute on the final distribution
that we get
[Applause]
okay so let's uh